- Hey, come on in.
(bouncy keyboard music)
Yes, push and
believe, you got it.
- Thanks for having
these chairs.
- Yeah, a lot of times they
want me doing the table,
I've done interviews in
the bed, I said guys.
- Why do you have
this chair here?
- Well, Joe, I'm a drummer.
- Really.
- Yeah.
- Alright, look, I saw
you drum on a chair
at South by Southwest.
- I got in a fight
down there too,
I got jumped by a
bouncer, how dare he,
I remember you buddy.
I was hosting an afternoon
show with different bands,
and this rock or heavy--
- Dirty type.
- Yeah, wearing a denim
jacket and Doc Martins.
- Yeah you scumbag.
- You jerk, Doc Martins,
what is this, '89 in London?
Are you listening to Madness?
I'm real and here
with Joe DeRosa.
- That's right.
- So he grabbed the mic and
goes, 'this guy's not funny,'
you don't grab the
mic from somebody,
and he threw the mic.
- The bouncer didn't
take your side?
- He saw fighting and he jumped
on me, and I kicked his ass.
- Can I do somethin' real quick?
- Yeah.
Fuck yeah!
You turn over that chair.
- Because you want that
to be the Doc Martins man.
- Mhm.
- Y'know what, let's go another.
- You're taking your shoes off?
Representing Doc?
- For our exercise,
they can be Doc Martins.
Let's put 'em on the chair
to represent the man.
- Who attacked me.
- Not we stand it up.
- And I drum on him.
- And you drum on
the man's dick.
- Watch this, here we go.
One, two, three, four.
One, two, three.
- Four.
What do the hits represent?
- South by Southwest,
that jerk who hit me
and jumped me and the
bouncer, I kicked his ass,
I work with kettle bells.
- Yes, yes!
You got extra sticks?
- I, y'know what I
knew you were here,
I got extra sticks, I
say we drum together,
I'll follow your lead.
- Right, and y'know who
I'm gonna pretend this is?
A guy, today, accused me
of spamming on Twitter.
- Block 'em.
- I blocked 'em, I blocked
'em, block you block you.
- Let it out Joe, wow.
Fuck yeah.
See ya' later jerk.
I'm gonna sit back and relax.
- I don't feel good right now.
I feel like I'm gonna
throw up a little bit.
- Are you serious?
- I ate a bunch of doughnuts
before I came in here.
- You want me to put the
drumstick down your throat?
Gag on it.
He went there.
- It went there.
- Push.
- And believe.
- You got it.
- Wooo, yes, we
did it everybody,
DeRosa and Stevens,
back together,
exercising demons,
South by Southwest,
you don't do that to me.
If you liked the video,
tweet me at Brodyismefriend.
Let's go viral,
let's break records,
let's put me on the map,
with the help of you.
Got something to say?
Leave me a comment,
'cause I'm readin' 'em.
Let's see that
view count higher,
it's like a telethon, you're
helping out Brody's kids.
Brody's gotta eat.
We can do it together,
push and believe.
Hashtag yes.